as i say i'm really proud of our team
um buffalo is an outstanding
team they're 4-0 for a reason but i'm
really proud of our guys
um i'll be happy to answer any questions
i can
hey john turnovers and penalties have
been issues for you guys the last two
weeks you're pretty good
at both of those areas to start starting
the season what's been the issue in the
last two games
well you saw the game i mean we got to
get turnovers from our defense that's
that's a big story here also
we're not getting any turnovers i think
we've got one the whole season maybe two
um guy made a great play on waller
uh we're playing short-handed up front
obvious passing situation and derek got
stripped
uh credit buffalo they got a good
defense but uh the penalties i'm gonna
take a look at them you can take a look
at them yourself and see if some of
those were
um you know ones you agree on or
disagree on i i disagree with a few of
them but
i'm a reader john obviously you're down
people on offense what does that do to
your calling would you like to be more
aggressive well if you're
watching buffalo play you know they got
two score leads they're not going to
give you chunk plays
we don't have a lot of time to stand
back there and survey the defense but
i give our guys credit we scored 23
points today we had four points called
back on a
alignment error that we've been in that
formation a thousand times
um you know we played pretty good at
times on offense
uh with our fourth different right
tackle our third different left guard
and a number of new receivers so
we'll take a look at the film uh but we
tried to stay aggressive
we made some plays down the field one of
them was called back obviously it hurt
us
how do you kind of make sure that this
doesn't
you know grow into anything bigger you
know losing streaks
well you know we're not going to get
into all this you know we got a good
young team
we're playing uh a lot of people i'm
really proud of our first quarter
anybody's played a tougher schedule than
us tell me who it is you know we played
monday night against the saints
across the country on a short week
against the patriots
and the buffalo bills are undefeated in
a playoff team and we're not going to
get any sympathy next week either going
to arrowhead so
this is a great opportunity for us to
continue to get better
and look at our young players and i'm
proud of them we've been in
been in all these games and we've won
two and lost two in the first quarters
and the
was your biggest books uh in coverage
against gates today
ah number one he's a great player and
you watch uh buffalo's offense they do a
lot you don't know exactly where diggs
is
and he's not the only weapon that
buffalo has john brown is a big play
receiver
the quarterback can complete passes
left-handed the guy's a beast standing
back there
uh singleton he's a good runner they got
a pretty good attack
and uh diggs can make plays in the slot
he can make plays outside he can make
plays in motion
and um he's proven he's one of the elite
receivers in football we struggled at
times
ah you know we got stuffed on a couple
short yardage runs which is very
disappointed twice we got rejected
uh in gold once and jacobs uh once
uh yeah you kick yourself but we were in
that football game
we were in that football game and uh i
think we only punted one time
so we knew we were going to get the ball
back we knew we could move it
and unfortunately we didn't score enough
hey john your differential in the fourth
quarter is negative four
uh three of those are fumbles by the
quarterback derek how tough does that
make it to win when that's happening in
the fourth quarter and also
why was uh paul gunther the defensive
coordinator up in the press box rather
than down on the sidelines that usually
that's a loaded question um first of all
the the fumbles
when you're in an obvious passing
situation and you're throwing the ball
and they know you're throwing the ball
uh you're going to get every coverage
and every stunt and every look known to
man
and the great past rushers they salivate
in those situations so
you know the situation has a lot to do
with it we're very predictable and
one dimensional in those times but we
still got to clean it up
we're playing a lot of different
alignment there's a lot of things that
have gone into that problem
and paul gunther went up in the field so
he could see better
we're playing a lot of new players and i
think it worked out pretty good i think
his communication was good with the
middle linebacker from the box and i
think he was good communicating with the
staff as well
john it seemed like the like
for the first time this season we were
really unable to get the run really
established and get josh jacobs going
what would you
attribute
well you know they're they're a good
defensive team i'll just leave it at
that
they were a very good rushing defense
they gave up some yards last week they
probably got ticked off
they probably have a lot of pride over
there matter of fact i knew that no they
do
they probably revved up their run
defense they probably said hey let's
make
let's make the raiders uh prove that
these backup receivers and some of these
backup linemen can do some of the things
that we want them to do
but i think a lot of it had to do with
that they loaded the box
they came with some timely blitzes and
um we still had some good runs at
lost but times again threw four games no
interceptions throws for over 300 yards
and makes kenny staples record as the
all-time
leader quarterback for touchdown passes
i apologize after a loss asking this but
can you just talk about derek's
performance
you know it's never good enough when you
lose he knows that i know that
statistics are great
he's a he's done a heck of a job for
this football team
all we've been through with the the
virus and and not having any off season
program and trying to break in
two rookie receivers and then losing two
rookie receivers and
not having trent ritchie and it's been
tough on him we played a great schedule
but i i wouldn't uh i wouldn't question
one thing about derek carr he is
giving you everything he's got and he's
performing pretty darn good
thank you guys